Along with this earthquake, a
tsunami warning was announced from Miyagi prefecture to the coast of Fukushima prefecture, but
it has already been opened.
Regarding damage to nuclear facilities, Fukushima Daiichi Nuclear Power Plant,
Fukushima
Daini Nuclear Power Plant and Onagawa Nuclear Power Plant are currently plants.  It
has been reported that there are no abnormalities in the data of the above.
Regarding human damage, we have received reports
of 4 people who are currently investigating the relationship with the disaster and 107 people who were injured
.
Approximately 30,000 cases are still out of power within the Tohoku Electric Power
jurisdiction, but most of them are expected to be resolved by the end
of the day.
There was a derailment between Fukushima Station and Shirai City Rod Station on the Tohoku Shinkansen,
but there were no injuries and all passengers in the vehicle had been
rescued.
It ’s not standing.